nous commençons la semaine avec johnny
jarre bonjour bonjour bonjour monsieur
caruge bonjour à toute la martinique
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes secrétaire général du ppm le
parti progressiste martiniquais
conseiller territorial à l'assemblée de
martinique également conseiller
municipal de fort de france et
conseiller communautaire à la casse m
johnny jarre alors un climat particulier
puisque à nouveau nous nous en nous
sommes dans une phase de banc de
confinement qui ne dit pas son nom mais
enfin de voilà de restriction de notre
circulation
ça s'agite ici ou là on l'a entendu ce
matin dans l'enseignement les collèges
les lycées
et puis bien sûr dans le secteur
économique où vous disiez récemment
encore dans une interview vous même
johnny jarque aujourd'hui beaucoup sont
en mode survie et qu'il y a une très
grosse inquiétude comment vous regardez
ce nouveau confinement
oui ça fait plus d'un an que la vie a
changé cette pandémie ce qu vide la
crise sanitaire car provoqué à la fois
une crise sociale une crise économique
majeure fait qu'aujourd'hui mais
beaucoup de personnes sont en mode
survie c'est à dire cherche havre le
minimum manger boire et conserver sa
dignité
donc il faut arriver à passer cette
épreuve dans les meilleures conditions
pour qu'il y ait le moins de souffrances
et de difficultés
c'est pour ça qu'il faut aussi anticiper
politiquement pour trouver les solutions
et les remèdes pour passer ce moment
difficile qui dure déjà depuis un an
aussi bien pour les très petites
entreprises que les poulets personnes
qui sont malades parce que c'est vrai
que cette pandémie est très dangereuse
sur le plan sanitaire
quand on regarde le brésil et aux
etats-unis et au brésil
c'est plus de 300 mille mois au brésil
les intérêts des gens chaque seconde
voilà au ppm qu'est-ce que quel est
votre positionnement par rapport à la
campagne de vaccination parce que est ce
que vous vous y voyez un espoir que
d'ici quelques semaines ça puisse
modifier profondément les choses
écoutez c'est aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de remettre comptes locaux vides donc
effectivement la vaccination est
certainement la seule on va dire la
seule thérapie
distante sachant que nous laissons aussi
la liberté alors c'est une position très
individuelle que je prends puisque nous
laissons aussi puisque aujourd'hui on
voit bien que la société très divisés
sur la vaccination ou pas le type de
vaccin astrazeneca pfizer et autres donc
nous laissons n'avons pas une position
ferme de façon à ce que chacun en
fonction de ses convictions de ses
valeurs mais moi personnellement je suis
pour le vaccin parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est soit ça soit le
risque de se retrouver en grèce en grave
danger de et de santé et aussi de
propagation du virus comme on le voit
aujourd'hui puisque le niveau de
propagation d'intensité a augmenté
considérablement martin vous même vous
vous êtes vacciné où vous vous êtes prêt
à vous vacciner dans les prochains jours
les prochaines semaines johnny jean
alors j'ai pas été vaccinés parce que
j'ai eu le coup vide et jeux légers une
forme assez sévère et donc je ne
souhaite ça à personne
effectivement de toutes les façons le
moment venu puisqu'il ya une période
entre le co vider le moment la
vaccination seront autorisés qui sera
mise en place
mais une fois que ce sera fait j'y vais
le faire personnellement
la question se pose d'autant que nous
sommes à l'orée d'une campagne
électorale pour la pour la ctn et
certains aussi se demande comment les
choses vont se passer pour le 20 juin
date du premier tour de ces élections
et justement il faudra du personnel même
si beaucoup de choses vont se passer
comment dirais je pars par internet de
par voie numérique
enfin le jour du vote il faut bien
qu'ils aient des bureaux de vote ouverts
quoi quand même même si on va inciter
peut-être des votes par procuration et
ses doubles procuration peut être même
un vote par internet qui ces gens de
toutes les façons avec cette capacité de
résilience individuelles et collectives
nous sommes condamnés à nous adapter la
pandémie nous a mis face à notre réalité
est une organisation qui doit nous
permettre à la fois de permettre aux
enfants de continuer à aller à l'école
et d'apprendre mais aussi à ceux qui
n'ont pas les moins deux villes de
pouvoir au moins de 5 minimum d'activité
je pense au travail on est dépendant
donc après le mode électoral vient de là
le jour du vote effectivement il y aura
une organisation qui sera mise en place
et je pense que c'est trouver bien placé
le curseur avoir un juste milieu qui
permettrait à la fois de maintenir une
sécurité sanitaire pour tous ces cas
c'est le niveau de propagation du virus
j'espère que les mesures qui ont été
prises le permettra dans les semaines à
venir pour que nous puissions revenir à
une vie entre guillemets quasi normale
assez rapidement mieux les matinées
clémentine hickey respecteront en termes
de discipline les conditions de sécurité
sanitaire c'est à dire distanciation
c'est-à-dire lavage des mains avec le
gel hydroalcoolique c'est-à-dire aux
masques et mieux à mon avis nous allons
revenir une vie quasi normale le plus
rapidement possible c'est ce que nous
espérons tous johnny jarre la ctm est ce
qu'elle accompagne comme il faut avec la
majorité qui est aux manettes là pour
quelques semaines encore avant le vote
est ce que la ctm justement
fait bien le job quoi et puis notamment
quel est votre avis sur le plan de
relance territoriales face à cette
situation
alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui et dans
ces temps difficiles nous le souhaitons
à personne mais quand on dit oui il faut
avoir de la responsabilité de
l'anticipation de la vision
malheureusement tout ce qui est mis en
place aujourd'hui ce sont des gouttes
d'eau c'est très largement suffisant pas
pour besoin d'autant que les effets
économiques et sociaux aujourd'hui sont
en train de se de s'intensifie
considérablement et c'est vrai que je
pense qu'il faut qu'une nouvelle
1 un projet un vrai projet parce que
malheureusement cette situation arrive
parce qu'il n'y a pas eu de projet
pendant les cinq six dernières années
qui fait que la martinique se trouve
aujourd'hui en grand et en graves
difficultés et les martiniquais eux
mêmes et à tous les niveaux culturels
économiques sportifs et autres
donc même si cette situation est inconnu
il ya un an ça fait maintenant un an que
nous avons cette expérience donc il faut
absolument
moi je ne vois pas de plan de relance je
suis désolé certes il ya des mesures
avec des êtres principal a qui ont du
mal à arriver véritablement au niveau
des gens c'est à dire entre le moment où
les décisions sont prises et les mots ou
le moment où l'argent est effectivement
à risoul la subvention le soutien
l'accompagnement et où elle mis en place
il ya un décalage très important qui ne
devrait pas y avoir avec des directement
qui sont anormalement haut
donc il ya un vrai projet à mettre en
place et vous ça qu'il faut une offre
une alternative politique majeur par
rapport à ces élections qui doivent se
réaliser
telles qu'elles ont été arrêtées en
termes de dates de façon à ce que le
nouveau projet pour la martinique puisse
repositionner la martinique dans une
dynamique de projets avec de l'ambition
pour que les martiniquais zélie martin
caisse 5 véritablement accompagner dans
leurs difficultés au quotidien et avant
une espérance de sortie de la crise
devenez un jour vous êtes sévère quand
même sur le bilan global de l'équipe
sortante vous dit même qu'il n'y a pas
eu de projet pendant la mandature
pendant les cinq ans et demi là qui sont
déroulés vous dites qu'il n'ya pas eu
projet en tout cas s'il n'y a pas une
projet y en a certains qui ont peut-être
abouti on pense notamment aux transports
c'est une deux
un de vos domaines de prédilection les
transports il y en a qui disent que ça
marche quoi avec martinique transports
alors qu'on soit clair le transport est
segmenté après cinq ans et a le nord le
sud et la casse m qu'on soit clair
aujourd'hui il n'y a que quelques bus
neufs le transport s'est dégradée sur
fort-de-france la matin chercher à
saint-joseph - de plus - le bus - ce
drame achats des usagers moins de fric
ans les gens attendent plus de temps
pour récupérer un bus aujourd'hui le
fait d'avoir des bus neufs ne signifie
pas qu'on est dans la modernisation
il n'y a pas de vision globale il n'y a
pas de schéma de transport il n'y a pas
de prise en compte de tous les
transporteurs par taxi coop qui ont
travaillé aux risques et périls pendant
des années on regarde bien dans le sud
donc les problématiques en cinq années
il faut regarder l'évolution sous cinq
ans et les quelques bus neufs ne doivent
pas donner le sentiment qu'il ya un
système qui organise hémodialysés avec
un tarif unique et qui permettent à
chacun de passer du maritime ou
terrestre
avec un ticket unique et pouvoir se
déplacer 2 go rivière à sainte anne en
passant par le noir pratique le nom
caraïbes où le sud câble chauffant et le
suggérait donc aujourd'hui un vrai
travail en retard
énormément de temps sur ce plan là et je
suis désolé il ya eu des coups il ya eu
des petits coups les seuls projets qui
aboutissent ce sont des projets qui
étaient déjà engagés avant 2015 quand je
repense au lycée schoelcher c'était bien
avant 2015 le bio du cinéma aussi
c'était bien avant 2015 au niveau de la
culture donc un certain nombre de
projets aujourd'hui faire du coup par
coup n'est pas faire un projet de
développement et de développer la
martinique au service de l'intérêt
général malheureusement quand on est en
crise sanitaire économique et social et
que la 7e se permet de terminer avec un
excédent de plus de 100 à 150 millions
d'euros sur l'année 2020 vous allez voir
c'est ce qui sera voté entre 100 et 150
millions d'euros ça veut dire que vous
avez pompes vont fonctionner dans la
dans la poche des martiniquais je pense
à l'augmentation de l'essence en 2017 à
l'augmentation des droits de mutation
qui fait que quand vous voie d'un
terrain ou une maison
eh bien vous payez plus cher depuis 2010
est à cause de la hausse fait pas la
septième de la gouvernance actuelle et
que en même temps cet argent là il est
simplement déposer dans les côtes de la
ctm c'est à dire que vous diminuez le
pouvoir d'achat des gens qui sont déjà
en difficulté et en même temps cet
argent dont
alors que l'argent doit travailler pour
créer de la richesse et créer de la
valeur ajoutée
donc je suis désolé je ne peux pas faire
le constat de la situation réelle que
nous vivons au quotidien avec des
milliers de personnes qui viennent nous
voir pour nous expliquer qu'il faut
trouver des solutions et nous sommes
dans cette dynamique de solutions
alternatives
justement johnny jarre pour conclure
l'alliance c'est le nouveau nom de la
famille politique vous essayez de mettre
en place alors avec beaucoup d'anciens
membres de u2 pmn ensemble pour une
martinique nouvelle l'alliance et serge
letchimy on a l'impression que vous
n'êtes pas encore tout à fait prêt pour
ces élections territoriales même
l'impression que serge letchimy y va un
peu à reculons il est même pas encore
candidat officiel la non pas du tout pas
du tout non seulement nous sommes prêts
nous sommes dans notre situation nous
sommes dans l'organisation mais non
c'est pas parce qu'on ne communique pas
qu'on travaille pas et c'est ça la
réalité aujourd'hui on a l'impression
qu'il faut communiquer il ya des gens
qui communiquent et ses creux et on ya
des gens qui ne communiquent pas et un
travail de fond qui se fait ce qui
compte c'est travaille au service de
l'intérêt général des martiniquais ce
n'est pas de communiquer vous savez voir
pouces habillez vous donnez une
devanture
nous sommes dans l'humilité du travail
que nous accomplissons et le moment
venir là comme l'homme d'un moment venu
par de la communication viendra de façon
à ce que les matinées caser les
martiniquais ensemble en toute confiance
puisse donner cette confiance a des
ailes à cette dynamique d'alliance avec
serge letchimy comme tête de liste parce
que nous savons tous qu'il a toutes les
compétences requises toutes les qualités
personnelles requises et nous viendrons
le moment venu face à ceux qui comptent
lancer le projet les idées les valeurs
c'est ça l'essentiel
c'est pas le côté fun providentiel c'est
pas non plus ni une revanche ni une
vengeance on est dans une dynamique de
projet de vision pour l'avenir pour une
espérance nouvelle une vraie résidence
individuelle et collective pour la
matinée merci johnny genre d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
bonne journée merci a dit le curieux
clerville pour la prouesse technique
et puis vous retrouver 10 me de lamaze
voilà bonne journée à toutes et à tous
trop